hi this is presh talwalkar in this video
i'm going to teach you a cool trick so
you could quickly square any number
that's in the 50s in your head
let's start out with 57 squared
the trick involves two steps
the first step is to square the units
digit
in 57 squared the units digit is 7
and squaring 7 gets us 49.
the second step
is to take 25 plus the units digit
so we're going to take 25 plus 7
to get 32
and that's our answer 57 squared is
3249.
for another example 54 squared
we want to square the unit's digit of 4
to get 16
then we're going to take 25 plus 4 to
get 29
and our answer is thousand nine hundred
and sixteen
for fifty three squared the units digit
is three
and when we square that we have to make
one adjustment which is we wanna write
it as
a two digit number so three squared is 9
we need to write that as 0 9
then we go ahead and do the second step
which is 25 plus 3
and that gives us 28 so when you're
doing this trick always remember that
when you square the units digit you need
to make it a two digit number
i'm going to briefly explain why this
trick works
when you square a number in the 50s
algebraically that's the same
as taking the quantity 50 plus x squared
where x is a digit from zero to nine
if we expand this out
we end up with one term of two thousand
five hundred
the middle term is a hundred x and the
remaining term is x squared
so we can rewrite the x squared and we
can take the terms that are highlighted
in blue and factor out a hundred to get
a hundred times twenty five plus x
and this is where the formula comes from
the x squared is where we get the rule
to square the units digit
and the 25 plus x is where we get the
rule
to take 25 plus the units digit
i hope you liked this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory
you can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions on twitter
at preshtalwalker and you can get my
books at amazon